this is so cool I was in Yellowstone for
a year and a half my job was to shed
light on wolf behavior in a natural
landscape a lot of times wolves get
persecuted and this was an opportunity
for me to just just show wolves for what
they were for being large beautiful
megafauna carnivores
being there for as long as I was
inherently you're gonna see so many
different unique wildlife events I'm
assigned to be wolves but you know if I
see an incredible thing happening over
here it's of course I'm gonna photograph
that you can't can't look away that's
not what we do
[Music]
it was a huge aspect of life and death
in Yellowstone it's always a bit hard
when you're empathetic human to see an
animal suffering you know this little
elk calf it's like fresh to the world
and all these animals around me and then
it's like welcome to reality now your
food for wolf pups
you know photographing wildlife is
always this balance between what you can
control
and what you can't control
if you can't talk to animals what do you
think she's doing even if you could it's
like the part wouldn't be ethical de
Becque oh yeah could you just like take
your whole family of wolves and go up on
that Ridgeline and like oh the moon's
right there could you just start howling
in front of the moon I mean country
setting up camera traps becomes a little
monotonous and so sometimes you like
pretend to be whatever your subject is
whether it's like a wolf or a bear and
you kind of like goof around and lighten
it up but a lot of the work that I did
end up being skiing around snow shooting
around in the backcountry trying to get
close to the wolves being out there and
being by myself you kind of worry about
being a bear snack as well but
thankfully I had a lot of training
informally growing up my brother and I
had to walk a mile and a half to the bus
stop the way back was always like this
big explore adventure session where we
walk on the frozen brook and hopefully
fall through I wasn't so bad being
self-sufficient was a big part of our
childhood and I didn't realize how much
I'd use it now as an adult because yeah
there's definitely some risks involved
with the whole goal is to make pictures
that people haven't seen before and
inherently that means pushing boundaries
you know if it was easy somebody else
would have probably done it
[Music]
you